Okay,
so today I'm talking to Dr James W
pennebaker.
He is professor of psychology at the
University of Texas at Austin,
and the Executive Director of Project
Twenty Twenty one aimed at rethinking
undergraduate education at that
university.
His cross disciplinary research is
related to linguistics,
clinical and cognitive psychology,
communications,
medicine,
and computer science.
He and his students have explored
natural language use group dynamics and
personality in educational and other
real world settings.
He has demonstrated that physical health
and work performance can be improved by
simple writing or talking exercises.
Dr Pennebaker has received numerous
awards and honors has written or edited
more than 250 scientific articles as
well as nine books,
including more recently expressive
writing words that heal and the secret
life of pronouns.
He also happens to be one of my favorite
psychologists.
Welcome Dr Pennebaker.
I'm very much looking forward to talking
to you guys to be here.
Thank you.
Great.
So,
um,
as you may know what,
because I think we've talked about this
a little bit before.
I developed some computer online,
computerized writing programs with my
colleagues,
one of which we call future authoring.
One's passed,
all three ones present,
all threatening.
There are a suite of writing program
said they were heavily influenced in
their design by your research.
Um,
my lab's been interested in narrative
for a long time and also in,
in clinical work and also in the
application of psychology,
uh,
in the,
in the real world setting and the
practical setting.
And I spent a lot of time developing
tests to help employers screen for
employees and we got pretty good at
that.
But while I was doing that,
I was constantly bombarded with
questions from managers of middle
managers usually have medium sized and
large corporations telling me that it
was all well and good if we could hire
better employees,
but they wanted to know what they could
do with their poorer performing
employees,
uh,
because that was a continual,
an intractable problem.
And I thought,
well,
you don't have that much interaction
with them and it's not that easy to
solve people's problems.
So there's probably not a lot you could
do,
but I kinda got sick of telling people
that over and over.
And so I scoured the literature.
It was at that point,
probably about 15 years ago,
10,
15 years ago that I came across your
research on expressive writing,
so maybe you could start by telling us
what you,
what you learned and how you went about
it.
A little bit of background.
I'm a social psychologist by training,
so
I.
I don't have any clinical training.
I'm a.
most of my career has just been
stumbling upon one idea after another as
opposed to approaching anything with a
clear set up where it was going.
I had been looking at mind body issues.
I've always been interested in how
psychological factors influence physical
health and mental health and I came
across a fighting years ago that just
bugged me and that was people who have
had a major traumatic experience in
their lives that were much more likely
to get sick and people who had not.
Now that that was an old finding,
but as I dug in more deeply,
what I discovered was people who had a
trauma and kept it secret.
We're far more likely to have health
problems than people who had the same
trauma,
but who talked with others about it and
it made me wonder what if we brought
people in the lab and had them actually
write about it,
some kind of trauma,
ideally one they hadn't talked to other
people about would that influence their
health and that was really the
underlying idea.
So the very first study was done in 1983
and we brought in about 50 people.
Some of them were asked to write about
the most dramatic experience of their
lives.
The other half were asked to write about
superficial topics.
I'm simplifying this study some and they
wrote for four days,
15 minutes a day,
and they also gave us permission to
track their student health center
records.
These were college students and this was
at a private college where the student
health center was right next to the
dorms.
Well,
what we discovered was that those people
who were asked about traumatic
experiences ended up going to the
student health center at about half the
rate as people in our control condition.
The ones who had regretted about
superficial topics over the next three
to six months and this was a really
studying,
finding it was,
you know,
what I kind of hoped would occur,
but I never,
uh,
I was so thrilled that it actually
worked.
And then we did another study that was
very similar and here again,
we had half the people write about
traumas have right about superficial
topics and they just,
they,
they wrote about trauma or superficial
topics.
By a flip of the coin.
We decided which are the two topics
they'd write about and this time we drew
blood before we,
uh,
assign them to condition again after the
last day of writing.
And then six weeks later and the blood
was essay by a group of people at Ohio
state looking at immune function.
And again,
we found that writing about traumatic
experiences associated with enhanced
immune function and also reductions in
doctor visits.
And this now takes us to about 1988.
And by then other labs started to see
what we were doing.
And it's the,
the whole technique started to take off.
And then over the years,
more and more including my own found
generally positive effects,
not always,
but generally they're writing about
upsetting experiences had this saluatory
affected and influenced both health,
physical health and mental health.
And then later various labs found to be
related to all sorts of things
associated with,
uh,
increased,
memory,
cognitive functioning and so forth.
So,
so
if I remember correctly as well,
when you were doing the earliest
studies,
you were also influenced by Freud's idea
of catharsis.
And that was the idea that if,
if people had a traumatic or unpleasant
experience,
if they were encouraged to express the
emotions that were associated with that
experience,
that that would be curative.
That was partly Freud's hypothesis,
but it was a little bit.
It's important to.
It is absolutely consistent with,
with Freud's initial idea.
And what was interesting is because most
people listening to this podcast,
we'll hear Catharsis and they will think
that Catharsis means blowing off steam
venting.
And that's not actually what Freud
actually meant.
And it's interesting in Europe,
catharsis has a completely different
meaning than it does in North America.
So in North America we view it as
venting Freud and Jung and Europeans,
you'd Catharsis as connecting emotions
and thoughts and that is actually what I
was doing.
I really,
I had assumed that Freud meant venting
and we had found actually that people
who just blew off steam,
who he just expressed emotions actually
didn't show any health improvements.
It was only
what stick analysis.
Right.
And that was really fascinating about
the research.
So maybe you can tell us a bit about
that too.
Well,
I wasn't initially again,
uh,
I have never.
I had never been at a and been
interested in psychotherapy in here.
All of a sudden I was doing a study that
was essentially glorified psychotherapy,
which garbage speaking to clinicians.
And then the question was why does
writing about an upsetting experience
bringing about these changes?
And it's not a straightforward question,
but there's not a straightforward
answer.
And my lab and others started looking at
all sorts of possibilities and looking
at markers of inhibition,
you know,
the people holding back,
we're more prone to illness.
And what this did was to loosen them up.
We didn't find good evidence for that.
Other people had other hypotheses and at
some point I started looking at what
people were actually saying and I got
groups of people,
students who are in clinical psychology
to write the essays that people wrote in
on all these different dimensions and
what I found was that relying on people
to read these essays and come up with
some kind of deep understanding or even
predicting if a person would benefit or
not just didn't work.
It was too hard.
The stories were really traumatic.
They actually depressed a lot of the
people who were in our system who,
who were reading the essays.
So it occurred to me it would make much
more sense to come up with some
objective marker of reading these essays
and a computer program would be what I
needed.
Well,
it turns out back then,
this was now the early nineties.
There was no such program and
fortunately I'd take it a little
computer science in college and one of
my graduate students,
Martha Francis,
had actually done some done her
undergraduate degree in computer
science.
And so I asked Martha to essentially
help me to a computer program that could
go through and analyze the the language
of an essay,
and the idea behind it is really quite
simple.
You have the computer go in and look at
each word and you would compare each
word in the essay with some master list
of words.
So we would,
let's say we're looking for anger words.
We want the computer to count up all the
words associated with anger.
So we'd have this dictionary of anger
words.
And to get that dictionary we had to
make that ourselves.
We had to look in dictionaries,
thesauruses.
We had to have students generate anger
words.
And then we had all these rules of what
account,
what makes for an egg award versus not.
But once you have that list,
you go through and you have the computer
look at each word,
compare it with a master list,
and anytime it finds it anger word,
it just adds it up.
And at the end it adds up.
All the anger words divided by the total
number of words,
and it produces the percentage of total
anger words.
In an essay,
and we did this now for not just anger
words or sad words,
guilt words,
negative emotion words in general,
but we did positive emotion words and
then cognitive words,
words that suggested cause and effect
like cars because effect,
rationale where such as that,
and then as long as we were doing it,
we added more and more dimensions.
We,
you know,
we had pronouns and prepositions and
articles,
etc.
Etc.
And wE ended up with about.
Now there's probably 80 different
dimensions,
but when we went back and started
looking at essays,
we found that certain dimensions of
writing really predicted health
improvements.
Now we found that the use of positive
emotions was associated with health
improvement.
So if you cAn write an essay about the
worst thing in your life and still use
positive emotions,
it's a marker that you're going to show
health improvements.
The effects are pretty small negative
emotion words using a moderate number of
negative emotions is weakly related to
doing better as well.
But what turned out to be far stronger
was use of cognitive words.
Whereas like,
because effect where it's like
understand and realize no,
these are words that we now know are
markers of people working through a
problem.
Let me ask you a question about that
because I saw it a lot about that.
I thought that was really aN interesting
idea.
So,
um,
this question has to do with the
function of memory.
So it's,
it's pretty obvious that we don't and
count store what's the equivalent of a
videotape of the entire domain of
sensory experience when we're
interacting with people.
Um,
and,
and it just so obvious as well that that
isn't how memory works and that memory
is modifiable across time.
And so here's a hypothesis for you and
you tell me what you think about this.
It seems to me that the purpose of
memory is so that you can remember the
good things that happened to you in the
past and how they occurred and duplicate
them in the future and remember the bad
things that happened and figure out why
and change your course of lights and
your pathway in the future so that they
occur less frequently.
And so the cause and effect analysis
would be something like the adjustment
of a,
of a pathway map and it sort of reminds
me of the work that was done with rap
memory because the hippa campus seems to
store or something like cognitive maps
and maps almost by definition are are
are representations of ways to get from
one place to another and so you could
say maybe that you go from one place to
another and you fall into a hole and
that's very traumatic and so you,
you remember the pathway and how you got
there and analyze it and reconstruct a
different potential future causal
pathway so that you don't have to fall
into the same hole twice.
You know,
I don't know what you think about that,
but.
Well I think that actually I think that
works is true both the way you describe
it,
but also on a much broader metaphorical
level.
So for example,
a person who falls into an emotional
hole that their life is going well and
then their girlfriend dumps them and
they go and get drunk in a bar and wreck
their car.
That experience is incredibly,
incredibly complex and it,
unlike the rat,
what the human mind has to figure out
what in the world went on with my
girlfriend,
why did she leave me?
What did I do?
Why did I go get drunk?
Have I been drinking too much and right.
If to process that requires tremendous
cognitive capacity and what happens is
if it's something were humiliated about,
were really reticent to talk to other
people about it and we.
So we add languages,
a really efficient way to process
complex issues.
Yes.
Shared language,
you know?
Well,
so what I found in my clinical practice
very frequently is that I,
I think with,
with people who are traumatized,
they often encounter.
this is something else I wanted to ask
you both.
They often have an encounter with
malevolence as well as a,
as a,
as an encounter with just catastrophe.
So it's not only did something bad
happens to them,
it's often something bad that's been
consciously directed that the by another
person and they have a really hard time
mapping that,
especially if there is somewhat naive
people,
but then the other people who are
mentally affected by such things and can
recover are those who have no one to
listen to them because people,
it seems to me that most people think by
talking and unless you have someone to
talk to,
you actually don't get to think through
it and draw the appropriate,
let's call them cause the lessons.
So,
and then you also made this comment
about,
you know,
let's say the classic example I like to
use is that,
you know,
maybe you're a premed student and you
write the medical,
the g,
what is it,
what's the one for,
for medical entrance kept.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So you know,
you consider yourself as a pretty solid
student and that's a core element of.
You're like,
it's a predicate of the multiple maps of
your life that you use.
And then you write the end cap and you
end up with 20th percentile scores.
And so then what happens is that not
only is your map of the future now
rendered null and void,
but so is your map of you as a predicate
for president actions and also
everything about yourself that you
thought held true in the past has to be
reexamined and so it's something like
the the degree of trauma is
proportionate to the amount of the area
that have map that's disturbed by the,
by the,
by the unfortunate,
unexpected,
and sometimes the malevolent event.
ANd so then the other thing I was
thinking about with regards to this,
and I think this is more germane to the
immunological element,
is so it's obviously very,
very difficult for the mind to compute
how dangerous the environment is because
the environment in some senses
infinitely dangerous.
And you never know when something small
happens to you.
If it's the harbinger of something
that's terrible.
So because an ache in your side can be
the cancer that kills you.
So you might ask yourself,
given the complexity of,
of framing in an unexpected event,
how do you ever manage it?
And so part of it's temperamental,
so if you're higher in neuroticism,
things hit you harder and part of it is
based on your observed competence.
But the other part I think is something
like,
it's something like the brain computes
the proportion of times that you failed
in the past compared to the performer to
the times that you've succeeded and
calculates.
I liked that name,
danger in depths,
and then it raises up your average
cortisol levels in correspondence to how
dangerous the general environment as
being because that puts you on alert
more.
And the problem with the advantage to
being on alert is that,
well,
if anything else negative happens,
you're more ready to act.
But the negative consequences is the
cortisol is toxic and in reason,
you know,
in high doses across time.
And it also suppresses immunological
function and it also tends to suppress
prefrontal functioning as well because
the prefrontal cortex is more involved
in low,
medium to longterm planning and less in
short term emergency preparation
activities.
So I'd also like to know if you know
that,
that those ideas ring,
ring a bell.
So they do that.
There's an interesting.
So the,
there's another dimension that ties into
this and that is sleep,
so we know that sleep is intimately
related to cortisol is related to
depression,
is related to immune function,
is related to,
you know,
all of these systems are inter
correlated and the person who is dealing
with an upheaval that they're trying to
understand what they'd had,
don't have somebody to talk to,
end up not sleeping as well and part of
it is they're trying to process all this
additional information and this ties
into the idea of working memory that
they have less working memory.
They're not Sleeping as well.
Cortisol is is higher there and they are
also worse friends,
so when you talk to them,
they're distracted.
They're not paying attention and so all
of these things are working together to
undermine the person.
Now their cortisol hypothesis is a
wonderful hypothesis.
The killer problem is that the studies
that have been done with cortisol and is
linked to writing and trauma have been.
you'd have to stand back and look at the
overall studies.
It kind of squint and there's a weak
evidence to support it,
but it's not as clean as I wish it were.
Of course,
this has been the problem with,
with the writing and research,
but it's also the problem of all
clinical research that theory is,
you know,
once you start getting real data,
and this is not just self reports of p
of a client said,
oh yeah,
that was really great.
When you start to get a hard data,
everything is kind of off the table that
the effect sizes are very,
very modest.
Either way.
That's true of medical outcomes as well
for medical disease.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
so you're the downward spiral that you
sort of described there too,
could also account for,
could also account for the negative
health consequences post trauma.
I mean,
so you can imagine,
first of all is that the traumatized
person is going to be more reactive to
two additional trauma,
but also that as they,
as they,
as the effects of their failure cascade,
say across their friendship,
interfere with their,
uh,
educational function,
interfere with their sleep.
The quality of their life overall is
going to decline and that should also
produce multiple small stressors that
are going to compromise something,
including say that the decreased sleep
and maybe also alterations and appetite
and those might accumulate across time
and produced the negative health
consequences as well.
And don't forget the little smoke more.
Drink board,
take more drugs,
stop exercising.
Yes.
Kids out there.
When you have a trauma,
uh,
take care of yourself.
You're right,
right,
right.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
the first thing I do with my clinical
clients generally speaking,
is make sure that they're getting enough
sleep and try to reregulate they're
sleeping and also to make sure they eat
breakfast at least because that,
that without those two things,
it's very difficult for someone to get
themselves back on the straight and
narrow.
So.
So now when we designed the self
authoring program,
I think I had read,
I think it was researched by Laura King,
but I don't remember.
Somebody had taken your,
your writing exercises and applied them
to the future.
Had people write about the future
instead of the past and found similar
effects.
Was that Laura King?
Do you remember?
What was interesting was that study you
would think having people write what she
did
I thought was she'd have people write
about the past versus right about the
future versus both.
And her idea was that having them write
about both would be best because way
therapy sometimes works in that way.
so let's just work through your issues
and what are the implications for the
future.
She found That writing about both
actually wasn't very effective,
that having them write about the future
was beneficial or just the pass was
beneficial.
And since then there've been a lot of
other studies looking at having people
write about positive effects and,
or just negative.
And what is generally found is that
writing about positive effects is also
beneficial for health.
But the
kind of indicates is the thinking has
been official for health.
I think that's,
that's true.
And it's also like,
you know,
the best studies as I stand back and
look at the kind of,
the broad,
uh,
panorama of cover search is giving
people instructions to write really
loosely in the sense of here you write
about the most traumatic experience of
your life,
but in a lot of people haven't had
traumas or maybe you've come to terms
with traumas,
but friday about those topics that are
waiting upon you the most right now.
They may be positive,
may be negative if they may be most or a
little bit of both.
And,
and essentially that's what I encourage
people to do is to,
if you're having trouble sleeping,
you know,
set aside 15 minutes and just explore
your thoughts and feelings about issues
that are weighing on you.
Maybe something that you don't want to
talk about or something you don't really
even want to address.
Yeah.
Well when we,
when we set up the run you by the latest
research on the future authoring program
because you don't know about all of it.
But um,
so basically what we've done with the
future authoring program,
which is the one with which now we've
administered to thousands of university
students in different locales with very,
very stable results.
And the results are quite remarkable,
I think.
Um,
so the way the thing is structured is we
first get people to consider six
important dimensions of their life.
So we're,
we're kind of construing the individual
as something that's distributed across
dimensions,
practical dimensions.
So those are um,
intimate relationship friendships,
family,
career education,
um,
time spent outside of work and use of
drugs and alcohol because that's a
rabbit hole.
People can really go down and having a,
at least an idea of how you should
handle intoxicating substances is better
than just going into it blindly.
So the first thing we get people to
write about and loosely following,
following that idea,
it's like a free association idea and
psych gwen analysis,
right?
It's like,
but it also,
I think,
frees people up to make mistakes because
they get uptight if they have to do it
right.
You have to say,
look,
you don't have to do it right.
You can do it badly.
It's better than not doing it at all,
so we have them write about to envision
what they would like to take it,
have what they wanted on each of those
domains,
so like,
okay,
it's three to five years down the road.
Imagine you're taking care of yourself
and and as if you were someone you cared
about and that things were set up
optimally for you,
hypothetically,
what would that look like?
And what I found in my clinical practice
very frequently is that people are
afraid of specifying their future
because they're afraid of hope,
but also there's an avoidance element
which is that once you specify your
criteria for success,
you've also specified your criteria for
failure.
If you keep things vague and ill
defined,
then you can stumBle along without ever
really noticing that you're lost and
it's a really bad strategy in the medium
to longterm,
but I think it's effective as a means of
of well itself.
It's effective self deception in the
short term anyways.
they do that first and then we get them
to write for 15 minutes with with no
concern for spelling or grammar,
which I think we took directly from your
and just just sketch out what life could
be like three,
three years down the road if they had
what would be good for them.
All right,
so now that that also gives them
something to aim for it.
And so one of,
one of the things that we've,
we've,
we've been thinking through with regards
to having something to aim for is the
fact that the systems that utilize
dopamine,
the incentive reward systems,
which,
which basically produced most of the
positive emotion that have the kind that
people really liked only respond in
relationship to a specified goal.
So you,
you feel an incentive reward kit when
you're moving towards a value target.
And so if there's no value target,
there's no positive emotion in lights
except in consequence of direct
pleasure's sake.
But there's no ongoing excitement or
enthusiasm about tackling hard problems,
for example,
because there's no evidence that those
are related to a value destination.
And it's the entire dopaminergic system
that,
that responds to that.
And that's of course the system that
cocaine and drugs like that effect.
And so then we do something else which
we've introduced more recently,
which is we say,
okay,
now look you,
you specified the positive pole and that
gives you something to to run towards.
NoW we want you to think through the
ways that the faults that you have and
and they and the resentment and anger
that you hold for whatever it is that
you're angry about and resentful about
an unhappy about and to consider your
bad habits and imagine where those could
drag you three to five years from now if
you let them take the upper hand.
And so people write about that for 15
minutes and we think,
well,
that gives them a negative pole to run
away from like a hell to run away from
under heaven to run towards.
And there's some good evidence from the
animal literature that animals that are
running away and running towards.
At the same time,
our run faster,
they're more motivated.
And then in the second half they lay out
a,
a well articulated longterm
implementable plan and we try to get
them to deeply articulated,
say,
well,
you know,
drake it into eight goals,
rank order the goals if you attain goal
number one,
why would that be good for you?
Why would it be good for your family?
Why would it be good for broader
society?
what would you do with obstacles or
rose?
Okay.
So that's the pad.
And now at the university of rotterdam
at the business school there.
So it's the rotterdam school of
management.
I've been working with mckayla,
shippers there and her colleagues.
We've run about 7,000
people through that now.
And they,
the research indicates there's a bunch
of interesting things.
Um,
overall it's raised grade point average
about 20 percent and drop drop dropout
rate about 25 percent,
which is absolutely phenomenal.
Was larger effects that we would have
imagined.
But the effects are quite interesting
because,
you know,
most,
most interventions you rate if there's a
distribution of performance,
you,
you intervene and you raise the higher
performing people even higher,
you know,
absent a ceiling effect.
Performance.
This has the opposite of stack,
it raises the lower end up and so at.
At rotterdam,
the students that were most positively
affected were the ones who were
performing the worst and there are the
way we divided them up by gender and and
ethnicity,
so male,
female obviously,
but then we divided them into ethnic
hollander's,
so mostly caucasian natives and then non
western ethnic minorities.
So the males were underperforming the
females and then it was female dutch
natives,
male dutch natives,
female nonwestern,
ethnic minorities,
male non western ethnic minorities.
There was a big gap between the dutch
females said that non western ethnic
minority men within two years of
completing the program,
non-ethnic western minority men past the
dutch women even though women also
increased a little bit.
Yeah.
So and then we replicated that more
recently in Canada at a little college
called mohawk college and we found there
that men were underperforming women
again and then we divided them into how
well they were doing in high school
before they came into college.
And the worst performing males were the
ones who were doing poorly in university
before they hit college or the sorry,
the males who were in high school and
who had the worst grades,
were those who improved most with the
use of the future authoring program and
they all,
they did the whole thing in an hour
badly in one session.
That's very impressive.
Could you send me a copy of that?
I'd,
I'd love to see that.
No problem.
Copy the mohawk paper yet because it
hasn't been released,
but I can send you.
I'll send you the rest of them.
But yeah,
that's be assaults because these are the
issues.
Of course I'm dealing with right now on
here at the university of Texas trying
to find out,
you know,
most of the interventions that we're are
looking at is essentially a mean at a
lower social class.
Kids who are coming to college for the
first time,
who faced so many obstacles that the
upper middle class students aren't even
aware exist.
Well we're,
we're,
we're trying to think through why this
works.
You know.
And so part of it is,
I think,
and I've thought this through a lot,
and part of it is I think that schools
before college never require really
require kids to make a decision and they
don't teach them how to make decisions.
They never teach them that their life is
theirs to master,
let's say,
and that they have to make a plan,
but that the plant has to serve them.
We also have a suspicion that maybe men
will work unless they have their own
plan.
Maybe that's associated with trait
agreeableness,
although we were still investigating
that,
but there is no doubt that these,
at least as far as our research has
shown that these interventions,
the future planning interventions seem
to have a more salutary effect on men.
But the men are under performing,
you know.
So for some reason the women don't have
the same problem,
but it's something like males won't work
unless they have their own reasons to
which,
which wouldn't surprise me given that
males are more disagreeable than
females.
So it's certainly possible.
But you know,
the,
the effects on dropout at mohawk college
for walloping about 50 percent decrease
in the first semester,
and we,
of course,
that's when kids always drop out.
So there's something about having a
plan.
So we are thinking to that,
what's happening is,
and this kinda goes back to your
comments about both positive and
negative emotion,
it's,
it seems to be something like
uncertainty reduction and so and so that
reduces the effect of doubt,
let's say.
And also tagging,
you know,
having the person designed a future,
they also want tags success with
positive emotion and that carries them
forward potentially through obstacles.
So
yes,
it'd be very interesting to analyze the
essays that these people wrote using,
uh,
using our computer program.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I think we may have done that,
if I remember correctly,
we may have done that with,
uh,
with the,
rotterdam study,
but I'd have to look because we've used
your l rwc a couple of times to look for
the same sort of phenomena.
Um,
we've also done that to look at whether
or not we could extract out big five
traits from,
for writing samples and that's also
possible.
So sometimes I'm less sanguine about the
big five approach because language and
self reports are really,
really different animals.
Yeah.
well,
I'd like to talk to you now if you would
about,
um,
about your now you,
you,
you did the computer analysis and words
and that got you interested in different
categories of words.
Correct.
And a whole book on pronouns.
Part of the reason I want to talk to you
about pronouns,
apart from the fact that I'm interested
in this,
I'd been embroiled in a political
controversy in Canada for the last five
months that they,
there's been legislation here formulated
at the federal level.
It's already in place,
provincial level mandating the use of
what had been called preferred pronouns.
And I don't know if that's come to the
university of Texas at austin or not
yet,
but the idea is that people have,
um,
a nonspecific gender,
let's say,
have the right to choose pronouns by
which other people will address them.
And that's actually been mandated and
canadian law,
which is something I'd been objecting to
sephora asleep because I don't believe
the government should mandate language
content.
I think it's a massive error,
but.
But anyway,
so I have a specific interest in
pronouns and I know also the pronouns
are in a closed linguistic categories,
so they don't change that frequently.
But he wrote a whole book describing why
pronouns were so significant from a
psychological perspective.
Right?
And it's more,
it's not just pronouns,
it's a whole class of words called
function words.
And if you look at any text,
are you listening very carefully?
Most of what we convey our,
what we call content words.
These are nouns and regular verbs and
adjectives.
Most adverts,
and they're there,
the guts of what we're talking about,
but we have all these little words,
articles and the prepositions to have
for pronouns.
He,
she,
they,
it,
et cetera.
And in english,
there's only about 180 common pronouns.
Now the average person has vocabuLary of
100,000
words,
but only less than one half of one
percent of those words are these
function words.
Yet they account for 60 percent of all
the words we use,
they are,
they control how we talk and what they
are specifying is how we connect with
one another they are,
and how we connect with our topic and
how we think about ourselves and our
group.
And by analyzing these function words,
you get a really good sense of who a
person is and that that's the underlying
theory of the work I've been doing for
the last several years using this
computer program,
which is linguistic inquiries,
word count l,
iwc,
which I pronounced luke.
And the loop program is really just a
dumb program that it mostly is looking
at these function words.
So.
So tell us some things that you've found
with specific words.
So,
so,
um,
let's start off with,
with the most commonly used spoken word,
which is the word I,
I tells us so much about people.
And if you go into your email,
you're going to see that you use it
sometimes.
Sometimes in an email you will.
So for example,
people who are depressed use the word I
more than when they're not depressed.
People who are suicidal,
is it even more so,
one of our first studies was looking at
poet,
so either committed suicide or didn't.
And we analyze their poetry.
The suicidal poets did not use more
negative emotion words.
They didn't make more references to
death.
They used the word I more and why?
Because pronouns,
including telling us where we're paying
attention or if you used the word I
yourself focused and we,
and you know,
as a clinician that what are the
theories of depression is that it's a
disease of self focused at people are so
ruminative and looking inwards.
So much
so.
So let me ask you,
let me ask you a question about that.
So if that seems related to the,
to the psychometric finding that self
consciousness is a facet of neuroticism.
Uh,
let me ask you one other question along
with that.
but,
so because self conscIousness seems to
load with the negative emotions,
but also one of the things that I often
recommend to my clinical clients who are
socially anxious because I've watched
how they interact and because they get
so focused,
they don't look at other people.
They don't look at theIr face,
for example,
and that's thinking about how other
people are looking at them and they're
busy thinking about what to say next,
and so what happens is they stopped
looking at the face of the people that
they're there,
they're talking to or listening to them,
and so then they're extraordinarily
awkward and so what I've done is instead
of telling people to stop thinking about
themselves,
the set,
when you enter a conversation really,
really focused on the other people push
you attention outward because that seems
to activate their unconscious and
automatize professional,
let's say social skills and then you can
flow with the conversation.
That's exactly right,
and and to build on this,
the idea of people who are leaders and
status,
if you look at the two people you can,
you can tell with remarkable accuracy
who's the higher status by the person
who uses fewer eyes.
The high Status person doesn't use the
word I much.
The lower status person does it because
the high status person is looking out at
the world and the lower status person
is.
Your pointed out is looking inward and
you could take this to the bank,
go look at your emails and you'll see
when you're writing to someone of higher
status,
you tend to use I'm or,
and when you're writing to someone with
lower status,
you use it less so it's so.
Okay,
so let me.
Okay.
Let me tell you another observation that
I had.
You tell me what you think about this.
I'm going to tell you what to tell you
about a,
an observation from animation first.
So I've done some very in depth analysis
of various disney movies including the
lion king and the lion king involves on
a child and then an adolescent lion who
matures and so and the animators also
represented his father.
Now his father has a very interesting
face because it looks like this,
like it's,
it's,
it's focused forward and kind of staring
almost.
You were almost predatory because of
predatory gaze.
Gazes locked on someone else,
but.
And then the,
the adolescent lion who's kind of naive
and imbecilic in some sense is like this
all the time.
And so it seems to me that there's a
relationship between immaturity and and
self focus and maturity and outward
focus and in the lion king,
where when,
when the adolescent lion undergoes this
initiation,
right,
his face changes into one like this and
do one of determination.
And the other thing that,
that seems related to this is that,
you know,
when,
when people are speaking in front of a
group,
they often get self conscious and they
feel all the eyes on them and that makes
them self conscious.
And one of the things that I've
recommended to people who want to speak
to groups is never to speak to the
group,
just to look at one individual and then
another individual and then another
individual because that,
well that seems to foster communication,
but it also blows out the probability of
becoming self conscious.
So
that's exactly.
That's exactly right.
In fact,
I have recommended to teacher trainers.
So here's what you do at my university
for teacher training.
You give a a practice lecture and you
have the,
the camera is in the audience looking at
you.
That's the wrong way to do it.
The way that you should train teachers
is put a camera behind the teacher at
the audience and point out afterwards,
look,
they're not.
That guy's not paying attention to you.
That person is and the net.
In other words,
not making yourself focus,
making you that.
If you're training the teacher training,
a public speaker doing exactly what
you're saying,
you should give them the view of the
what the audience looks like and not
what you look like.
That's the exact wrong training.
Absolutely.
Okay,
so tell me what you think about this.
When I'm lecturing,
I pay attention to the people who are
paying attention.
Now,
most of the time,
most people in my lectures are paying
attention,
at least a reasonable proportion of
them,
but the ones that aren't,
well,
I don't know why they're not here,
but there's lots of reasons.
They might've had a bad night.
They might be overtired,
they may have taken the chorus by
mistake.
I mean god only knows,
but if I paid attention to the students
that are paying attention,
then I can read off their faces.
How the audience is thinking,
especially if I glance around,
but it's that intense communication from
individual to individual but seems to
make a lecturer or an interview or a
conversation really compelling.
That's exactly right.
And I think that's the secret to what
are the secrets to being a good teacher
and a good speaker is really being able
to watch.
And when also to the judge,
when all of a sudden you're starting to
lose,
you know,
you're,
you're also doing little experiments the
whole time.
Uh,
you know,
one of the things that people who are
relatively new is they start to lose
people and then they start speaking more
quickly,
which of course is precisely the wrong
thing to do
and they start less attention
because they get self conscious and want
to hide from the audience.
And then they get into a loop and things
just go,
you know,
the,
the worst speakers I'd ever seen stand
at the front of the,
of the audience with your head down and
mumble at their feet.
It's just painful.
I mean.
okay.
Okay.
So that's very interesting.
So,
okay,
so you talked about,
you talked about dominance.
What else have you learned about
specific words?
Um,
well,
a couple more things about.
I mixed with some others.
One is his honesty,
so the ability to detect deception
versus honesty as a function of how
people talk and what we find is that
we've done many studies where we induced
people to lie and tell the truth and
then we look at the transcripts of the
two.
When we find iS when people tell the
truth,
they tend to use it more that they're
owning what they're saying and the
person who was lying is psychologically
distancing,
distancing themselves from what you're
saying.
And then there's another feature is when
you're telling the truth,
you tend to use more words that are.
We used to call them exclusive words or
differentiation words where you use
words like except,
but without exclude word for you making
a distinction between west inner
category and not in a category that
these exclusive kind of words are.
You're being more honest because you're
saying what you did but also what you
didn't do.
And that's a really complex cognitive
tasks.
Whereas if you're lying and you didn't
do any of it,
just say what you did not do is just
beyond the capabilities of most people.
So both,
uh,
I were usage in these exclusive words
together do a pretty good job.
And,
and another one is also focusing on
details.
So if you do there with political
speeches.
Oh yeah.
And there had been some,
there's been some nice research on that
as well.
Jeff hancock,
for example,
is not.
Stanford has played with this idea quite
a bit when he was looking at all of the
rhetoric about what weapons of mass
destruction during the bush
administration that their,
that what he found was the
administrators were being using
deceptive language,
uh,
prior to,
to the u.
S were before prior to our going to war.
Huh.
So,
so,
so that opens up a whole completely
appalling,
an interesting scenario.
It's like me increasingly people are
using computer programs to analyze
personality and that sort of thing by,
by analyzing people's behavior on the
web.
That's exactly right.
And,
and we've been done,
been doing this a lot with,
with,
uh,
a political figures and if,
in fact I'm one of my graduate students
and like caitlyn,
Jordan,
how we've been,
we have a website,
it's called birdwatchers word
watchers.wordpress.com.
And like,
go in there,
you can see our analysis of trump.
And actually this whole election from,
from,
uh,
from my perspective as a scientist,
this has been a phenomenal electoral
season as a human being.
Not so much,
but
I'm going to get you,
when we're done here,
I'll email you and you could give me
some links.
Okay.
That I can put in a description here
where people can go look this sort of
thing up.
You bet.
So that's interesting.
So can you,
can you actually rank order politicians
in terms of the probability that they're
telling the truth?
I'm not.
So we have,
yes,
I could,
but I'm not sure I trust it very much
because one of the interesting issues
about deception is you've got some
people who are deceptive,
who are deceptive,
but they honestly believe they're
telling the truth.
And I think,
I think trump actually falls into that
category.
I think he actually believes what he
says.
Eddie might say just the opposite 10
minutes later and he'll believe that as
well.
Yeah.
So do you suppose?
No.
Okay.
So that's interesting because I've seen
in,
in poorly written undergraduate essays
you commonly see,
I think about it as fracturing at
different levels of the linguistic
hierarchy.
So you know,
if you listen to his schizophrenia
speak,
they're actually fractured at the level
of the frames.
And then if you listen to a manic speak,
they're more like fractured out the
level of the sentence or the paragraph
they can say a whole paragraph.
And then the next paragraph they'll say
something completely different.
It contradicts the first paragraph,
but there's no awareness of the
contradiction and poorly written
undergraduate essays.
There'll be a claim made on page one and
then a claim made john made on page two
that are completely antithetical.
And you know,
it isn't self evident that you become
conscious of paradoxes in your thinking
unless you act out both propositions
simultaneously and it produces a
conflict because you can hold paradoxes
recommendation without ever knowing it.
And so maybe maybe what happens with
someone who who does that sort of
contradictory speech is temperamentally,
they're very confident.
So they might be assertive,
for example,
something like that and maybe also low
end or high end stress tolerance.
So they're not anxious.
People are,
they're assertive and they don't really
care so much what other people think.
So they come across continually as
confident and so that would be more
temperamental confidence which is,
which is a form.
It's a funny thing because it's not
exactly the same as telling the truth,
but it is something more like believing
what you say or believing in what you
say.
That's right.
And what I think that the text approach
is better at is when a person knows damn
well they're telling,
telling a lie,
and,
and that's when our tails do better.
There's another phenomenon is called a
performative.
That's one of my favorite that you can
you hear.
And that is performatives are used in
linguistics and they're usually a phrase
and they might be something like,
let me assure you,
or as I said before,
or believed me when I say,
and if you have a performative,
it makes the entire sentence and you're
not able to detect if it's true or not.
So you can't establish the truth value.
Let me assure you that this is a glass
of water.
Now,
is that true or not?
Well,
it's.
Yes,
actually it is because I want,
you know,
I want to assure you that a glass of
water,
it's true because I want to assure you
that,
that it is,
even though it's not,
what happens is consciously we don't
know we do this,
but it's almost so our brain is kind of
trying to protect us and we throw these
up and I have another webpage that has a
number of performatives that you see in
president after president where the
president says something that the
beginning sets it up.
So it's performative and then the second
half.
Sure enough,
isn't it?
It is a lie.
Yeah.
Well,
so do you suppose that.
Okay,
that's interesting.
So do you,
do you suppose that.
So is the performative a marker for,
for,
for deceit,
isn't it,
is it,
is?
I think it is,
yeah.
So I think it is and it's edited fact.
In fact,
trump's great.
His best word is believe me.
So,
um,
I know more about the army than the
generals,
believe me.
Right,
right.
Was quite interesting.
He is,
and it's,
it is.
It's a form of performative,
which is he's really saying please
believe me that I know more that the
doctor,
that he doesn't use it that way,
but that's what it essentially is.
So it's,
it kind of makes you wonder if he thinks
that if people believe in that makes it
true.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's a funny thing because there is some
truth to the idea that
true things are what other people
believe.
No,
obviously you don't want to go too far
down that road,
but there is something,
I mean because for example,
a contract holds no truth unless there's
consensus around it.
So whenever the reality is dependent on
everyone agreeing to do the same thing,
then consensus is actually a very good
marker for truth,
you know,
because there's lots of situations where
you say,
well if we agree on all this then it's
going to be true.
That's what a contract is.
So,
so it's,
it's almost as if using words like that,
it's an attempt to establish a contract
where no contract can genuinely be
established.
I mean we can have a contract about
whether or not Iran has weapons of mass
destruction,
but we can certainly have a contract
about whether or not we'll go to war
over it.
Yeah.
With regards to two interesting words.
Well there's a,
there's a whole.
We could go for hours on this actually.
So another one that I've been quite
interested in is using these groups of
words and looking at how to people
connect and in terms of these function
words.
So what we could do is we can actually
calculate the percentage agreement we
have in our use of pronouns.
Prepositions are those articles,
conjunctions and so forth.
And we call this language style
matching.
And the closer to people are in their,
in their use of these words,
in any given conversation,
uh,
the more they are in tune with each
other
being on the same wavelength.
That's exactly right.
And it's not necessarily liking one
another,
it's been absolutely paying attention to
one another.
So two people in the midst of an
argument tend to entrain really closely,
just like two people madly in love.
Now we've done analysis of transcripts
of a speed dates and what we find is we
actually can predict who will go into
subsequent date at race somewhat higher
than the people themselves.
So what's happening is the rapid
establishment of mutual limitation.
That's exactly right,
exactly what happens from the australian
perspective when two children start to
play.
That's exactly right.
And we've looked at a.
One that I particularly liked was we
studied,
we looked at 86 dating couples.
He's a freshman in college and freshman
in college are in notoriously unstable
relationships,
which from my perspective is perfect for
research and wait to be in our studies.
They had to do instant messaging at
least daily with each other.
And to give Us 10 days of their igms,
which they did and what we did,
and we also ask them how good is your
relationship?
How likely will you be together in
several months?
And what we found was that we did a
shockingly good job at predicting who's
still be together.
Those people who were just average gut,
their their style matching score,
their average treatment score,
and we just got the top half,
80 percent.
We're still together.
Three months later,
if they were in the bottom half,
only 50 percent.
We're still together.
And self-reports people's self reports
about their relationship was absolutely
unrelated to whether or not they were
still together.
That's like dancing videos.
I've already started it.
That's exactly right.
So,
so what that really means in some sense
is that it this way is that the two
people come together and the two of
them,
it's as if they're making something,
they make something jointly,
that they're both acting out so that
they're uniting into something central.
Then you might think too that in order
for that to happen,
they have to be paying close attention
to each other.
And so you can't train with someone
unless you pay close attention to them
and certainly one of the best markers
for the utility of the relationship is
going to be whether or not the people
pay attention to each other.
Right?
Finding that's why children are so
absolutely desperate for adult
attention.
That's their currency.
That's exactly right.
Wow,
that's really cool.
Well,
if you go to another one,
because I've got another one,
a few,
three or four years ago,
I started working with much bigger
dataset.
So this was with,
uh,
about 25,000
college students who have been admitted
to my university over four years and I
got their admissions essays and these
essays are people's explaining why they
want to come to the university,
you know,
how they have overcome a difficult time
or something like that.
So each person wrote two essays and a,
we went through and started to do some
kind of a general analysis of word.
You're focusing on these function worms
and found that there was a central
dimension to language.
And this is a fundamental dimension and
it's when I'm calling it is analytic
versus narrative thinking.
People high on analytic thinking are
using high rates of articles and
prepositions at the other end of this
dimension are people who are using high
rates of pronouns on zillow,
reverbs,
conjunctions,
negotiations,
and so forth.
it is a coherent dimension and that any
texts is,
can be put along this continuum and in
fact,
it's like a fingerprint.
People who,
you know,
use words at this level tend to do so in
other,
in other emails,
other emails or natural conversation,
et cetera.
So are the narrative people using
metaphors?
Yeah,
they probably would have.
So tell me how you would tell the
difference.
Well,
as I said before,
before we get into metaphors,
metaphors are going to take us down a
rabbit hole.
So let's,
uh,
let's,
before we fall down the hole,
let me just point out this analytic
thinking.
What's so cool about it is we were able
to track these students grades over the
next four years of college.
And the higher they were on analytic
thinking,
the better they did in college.
And in terms of grades,
it was correlated about point two.
And it didn't matter if they were
physics majors or fine art majors,
if they were in engineering,
psychology,
uh,
music,
social work that this,
you could take this to the bank.
The more analytical person is in their
essay,
the better they do in college.
And part of it is as colleges based on,
on analytic thinking.
But it's also correlated with
intelligence.
It's correlated with sat,
which,
uh,
probably about point three,
point three five.
Oh yeah,
that's pretty good.
That's it.
It's really quite striking.
And what's interesting is,
is that we can now use this as kind of a
remote sensor to get a sense of how
smart somebody is.
So for analyzing,
you're a dangerous man.
I'm a dangerous man.
Parents.
yeah.
Yeah.
So that's another one that we've been
playing with many other things.
We've been doing a lot of work on author
identification.
So we published a cool article,
one of my graduate students,
Ryan Boyd,
and I've been focusing on last,
uh,
last play or a play that was attributed
to shakespeare with people didn't know
if it was or not.
And we were able to do some really smart
analysis showing pretty clearly that it
was written by shakespeare,
probably coauthored with another guy,
John Fletcher,
and we,
and we looked at some other manuscripts
that have been called into question that
have come out of the 17th century it.
so we know we've been taking this work
in all of these different directions.
Cool.
Okay.
So let's close thIs off by.
Why don't you tell us something about
what you're doing with regards to
revamping,
um,
undergraduate education at the
university of Texas and what you and
what your aims are and also why it was
that you were.
Exactly.
It all gets into my analysis of
language.
I was doing all of this work trying to
understand could I get a say a group of
initially to people,
but then it's been five people to
interact with one another on the
computer and if so,
can I track how they are interacting
with each other and get a sense of how
the group was working and working with
some computer scientists.
We were able to come up with a really
slick program to do that.
Then it occurred to me,
would it be interesting to do that in a
large class because I taught a large
introductory psychology class with a
colleague of mine,
sam gosling,
and we had 500 students in the class.
We had them bring a laptop to class one
day and we were able to break the class
into small groups of five each.
They could interact with each other and
we were able to track how they were
interacting and we get feedback to the
group trying to get the group to work
better,
so we using this style matching and we
can tell people whether or not people,
the members of the group were paying
attention attention to each other or
someone was talking too much.
We could ask him to not talk so much and
so forth,
and it worked.
The next semester we realized we could
use this idea and revamp the class from
top to bottom where we got rid of the
textbook,
so all readings were online.
We'd have a quiz at the beginning of
every class.
We would have break the class into
interactions more frequently.
Another word started to rethink the
class from top to bottom,
and then we moved it into an online
class so that we,
we were able to broadcast out and we
switched the format of the class.
It was like a tv show,
so we were behind a desk,
we'd have fake news,
we'd have at least one of us would be in
front of the green screen and some
other,
the place it used to be able to use to
know what I meant.
But I know as soon as I said that,
I realized I can't use that anymore,
but this idea of one of us would be on,
on,
uh,
in front of a scene somewhere on earth,
you know.
So.
So,
uh,
what else?
No,
I would say,
sam,
where are you?
It looks like you are in a balloon today
and so it looks like he's in a balloon
and so forth.
In any case,
the point was we turned this into a
television show and it,
what we found was that by broadcasting
this out to the 1500 students,
we sent it up because there was testing
every day that students were in class
every day they were focusing more on the
materials,
they were more engaged and it turns out
that their average performance went up
compared to when we taught it in the
past and more impressively,
we people who took our,
our online class did better in the other
classes they were taking that semester
class and the classes they took the
semester afterwards and uh,
it wasn't huge.
It was like a difference between a three
point one versus a three point two five.
And we reduced the disparity between
upper middle and lower middle class
students in terms of their performance.
So that historically we found one letter
grade between the upper middle and lower
middle class students and now and now we
had reduced it to point four letter
grade.
That's what was happening with the,
with the future authoring program.
That's right.
And that's.
And we heard that differential effect
on,
on the lower performing students.
Well,
it turns out we came across some
previous research that had found similar
effects,
but it deals with frequent testing.
The idea is kids who come from lower
middle class backgrounds by and large
went to crappy high schools and in these
high schools,
these were,
by the way,
our kids are all smart.
They're are always.
Most of them are the top seven percent
of their high school class.
But if they were at a crappy high
school,
they learned to get by by memorizing
because the tests were memorization
test.
And so these kids were great at
memorizing and then they come to a real
university where you're not tested on
memorization.
You have to think conceptually.
Right?
And historically when we taught those
classes,
the classes,
we had the usual three or four tests
over the course of the semester,
I would always get students in my office
walking in after the first test saying I
have never made a b in my life and I
just failed your first test.
That's impossible.
How is this even possible?
And I say,
how did you study while I had
flashcards?
I did this,
I memorized this,
and I said,
I told you memorization.
Does it work?
You have to think conceptually,
and that doesn't mean anything to these
kids,
but now you've got a test every day and
you fail that first test,
pow,
you fail the second test power and all
of a sudden you're realizing,
wow,
it's treated with memorizing doesn't
work.
Okay.
So you think what's happening is that
they're learning that memorization
doesn't work faster.
That's exactly right.
That's really funny.
And,
and they use these skills in their other
classes because they realized
memorization is not working in the other
classes either.
So how do they catch onto the.
Okay,
so now they know that memorization
doesn't work.
How do they figure out what does work?
Well,
it's been interesting moving to the
online world.
We create all of these videos,
which basically there's a video on how
to take,
how to study and there's another video
on how to take a test and another video
on um,
you know,
have you managed your time?
In other words,
now we,
we understand the problem a lot better
than we did before and so students are
taking advantage of these resources and
ended up doing better.
Huh?
That's cool.
So how long have you been doing now?
So after.
So we started the class the first year
in 2011 and then in the years afterwards
I started talking to people at the
university of Texas and elsewhere about
kennedy,
the big picture of education,
which was,
what the hell are we doing in education
right now?
You know,
the world has changed.
I've been asking myself,
uh,
no,
but the world's changed.
Why do we have three hour courses?
There's no logic for a three hour
course.
Why do we have a semester that goes from
the 1st of January to sometime in may.
There's no reason for that.
Why don't we have a half hour course?
Why don't we have a seminar course?
In other words,
why do we put things together with the
way we do?
And it turns out there's really good
reasons because in the early 19 hundreds
when you need it in a standardized way
of talking about credit and so forth,
and then we built computers to program
this in and we built buildings that we
knew how to use time and space and
location and and so that your computer
will tell you this class is going to
meet in this room at this time and your
final exam will be at this place and
this place.
We don't need all of that.
Well,
that's analogous to the conservation of
a physical structure and evolution.
That's exactly right.
And we don't.
And and what's interesting is the
university of Texas computer,
the read that the registrar uses can't
have make a half hour course.
It can't,
it can't change the semester.
It can't do any of these things at a
modern student information system.
Computer costs an unbelievable amount of
money.
And so what I'm doing is I am working
with the university and the entire
infrastructure to start to rethink
everything.
What should be the curriculum?
We don't need all these required courses
that we used to have.
It makes no sense,
but you know,
a lot of our requirements made a lot of
states 50 years ago and a lot of our
classes were flushed out classes.
We don't need flunk out clAsses anymore
and we can come up with with really
brief classes,
half our classes to learn a basic skill.
For example,
we have a requirement.
You have to have a statistics course to
take upper division psychology classes.
Do you really need the statistics score
as well?
Most of it you don't,
and if I asked my people teaching
statistics,
asking them,
do the statistics you're teaching,
are they relevant to today?
And they all say,
oh no,
not at all.
I mean I don't use analysis of variance.
I don't use t tests.
I use linear regression.
I use this,
I use that,
but we can't teach that in.
My view is if you're going to take my
upper division class,
you better know correlations and you
kinda know correlations up and down.
I could teach a correlation.
Of course.
That would be a point seven our corps
and download it and take it anytime.
I don't care where you take.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the,
I mean I've been using youtube a lot for
the last three years,
you know,
when I put started putting my lectures
online just just with an ipad,
you know,
um,
and by,
by the beginning of 2016,
I've collected about a million views and
I thought,
oh
that's,
that's a whole different thing than I
thought it was.
I thought youtube was for cute cat
videos.
And then I started thinking it through
what I thought,
oh no,
look,
here's the situation map for the first
time in human history,
the spoken word has as much staying
power and reach as books.
No more reach you could publish faster
and it can be broken up and communicated
and all sorts of chunks.
It's like,
this is absolutely revolutionary.
It seems to me that while you're in a
race against time,
that's exactly right because this is the
new world order and it's,
you know,
it's like every other part of our world
right now where we're dealing with the
future of ai and the future of,
of,
of everything that this really messes
with the world order because so much of
what we can teach can be put up there
and it,
you know,
because the correlations haven't changed
a hell of a lot in the last hundred
years.
You don't need to update your lecture on
correlations,
right?
One really good lecture on correlations,
more $10,000.
That's also very frightening.
That's exactly right.
And,
but then
we do need,
you know,
we,
we're talking now 15th century,
we do need a guild mentality.
If you're going to become a therapist,
a scientist or this or that,
you need to have some serious lack of
experience.
You need to have some serious experience
doing things in addition to learning how
to think and to get some smart feedback
on how to think,
how to,
how to come up to get up to the level to
understand what's involved in trying to
make a new size to make new advances.
It's an incredibly exciting time and I'm
working with all parts of the
university.
I have 200 people working with me.
I've got various,
you know,
we were dealing with a development
studio,
working on new ways of thinking of on
online and other technologies.
I've got a big research methods group
trying to find out what even works.
We don't even know what works and what
doesn't.
We're having to deal with extended
campus in terms of how we can push out
our,
our classes,
our information to the world in a way
that has some kind of financial value to
the university.
So we in this office
guys,
when you guys been thinking about
accreditation,
because it seems to me that the business
is the big issue.
The thing is is the ability to
disseminate valuable information was
once the university.
In some sense how to hammer lock on
that.
That's gone no more.
That's the thing that the.
The impediment to mass education at the
moment in some sense is the problem of
mass accreditation.
Universities still have a hammer
marketing out,
but there's no reason that they need to.
So I'm curious,
when you're thinking about the mass
distribution of education material,
what have you been thinking about?
The problems and the complexity is this
are unbelievable,
so some of it is the,
the nationwide bureaucracy,
so there are accrediting agencies that
that don't know how to use deal with
fractional credit,
don't know how to deal with a variable
calendar.
We've got financial aid issues because
they're based on these old systems as
well.
We're dealing with intellectual property
in terms of who owns the ip of a class,
is it the instructors at the university,
can university resell it?
How do we rethink this?
You know,
the idea of having free open classes is
great,
but it's not a very good business model
and this has been one of the problems
with coursera and edx and you're putting
your videos on online for free because
the reality is the costume
patrion,
you know,
hey,
you know about patriotism?
No,
it does really interesting.
It's a,
it's a platform that,
that,
that was developed because of the
difficulties that creative people were
having and monetizing their production.
And so with patrion,
people can voluntarily buy a monthly
subscription if they find that the
content that you're producing is worth
supporting [inaudible],
then they can donate monthly to your
patriot on account and they can either
do that on a monthly basis or they can
pay you a donation per video that you
put up.
And that's been a very,
I thought with my youtube content
because I wanted to professionalize what
I was doing to some degree to hire a
film crew and,
and to increase,
improve the audio and all of that.
And I threw up a.
I'm a patriot account online last april
when I found out about the technology.
just a curiosity and I got about,
I don't know,
60 or 70 people subscribing in the first
month,
so that was kind of interesting and it's
enabled me to hire a film crew and that
sort of thing.
But it's quite interesting because the
patriot on people,
although there's some perks they get,
like I said,
the higher donors,
a signed copy of,
of one of my books for example,
but mostly they don't get access to any
content that everyone doesn't get access
to,
but people,
people have a strong sense of
reciprocity and they're not completely
comfortable with the idea of getting
something for nothing.
And now the patriot on account is being
extraordinarily useful.
To me.
It's,
it's,
it's
very interesting.
Yeah,
we'll do it now.
For example,
you know,
and these are issues that we're
struggling with at the university in
terms of how do we do it because to do
one of our courses is really quite
expensive and you know,
talk,
you know,
10,
20,
$30,000
and trying to figure out the model for
it.
The one thing that we can do is we can
give university credit,
so that's,
that's,
that's one,
that's one hold that we have,
but it,
no,
it really does deal with a broader issue
and in our society which is,
is knowing the and knowing that and
knowing how to think sufficient to get
by in the real world or do you need the
official credential and hopefully we
both yes or no.
If it was a just world,
just knowing the material would be
sufficient.
It gives you no rapid way of telling the
charlatans from.
That's,
that's the,
that's the big issue and that's,
that's the big issue is that as the
credential becomes more important,
the knowledge becomes less important
because you can use that credential to,
to,
to play the system.
That's right.
That's exactly right.
So these are the kinds of things that,
that I've been dealing with and I,
you know,
trying to change a giant bureaucracy,
turns out it's not real easy and it has
all these built in assumptions that,
that are part of the structure.
Not only not only part of the cognitive
apparatus,
but actually built right into the
infrastructure.
That's exactly right,
and what I've found is the people at the
university had been very supportive.
I thought for sure I would run into
major obstacles,
faculty,
students,
administrators,
even the legislators,
because this is a public university are
all really supportive and even though
I've got support all around,
it's still just like swimming through
molasses because they're all of these
rules and regulations that had been
there sometimes for a hundred years
that's no longer serve a purpose.
You know,
that's,
you know,
maybe you know,
maybe you don't know about the typical
fortune 500 company over the last 30
years and the typical family fortune
three generations.
It's for the reasons that you just
described is what happens is that the
structure itself becomes so
anachronistic that not even the people
within it can change it.
something comes along that's that's
younger and it's built on different
presuppositions and just takes it out
and the probability that that's going to
happen to the universities,
in my opinion,
is overwhelmingly high because of
exactly the sorts of things that you
described.
It's structural.
it's built for a different century from
the late 18 hundreds.
Well it is and actually if you think
about it,
university started in the 14 hundreds
and it's amazing that they have survived
as well as they have.
That's for sure.
Well look,
it was really good talking to you.
I've enjoyed as much though.
I'd been a great admirer of your
research and I don't say that lightly
because.
No,
thank you.
There's a handful of psychologists that
have had a profound effect on me and
you're certainly one of them and I would
also say you're a spectacular rarity
among social psychologists in my
estimate.
I know that's a nasty thing to say,
but being partly a social psychologist,
I guess I'm allowed to say it to talk to
you again at some
point in the future,
maybe six months down the road or
something because you have all sorts of
things that people need to know about
and this is a really good way of telling
people about them,
so I'll email you and get some,
if you could think of three or four
links and a little description that
you'd like to go along with them,
put them on,
put them in the description of the
video.
I'll tell you when both the podcast and
the video will be up,
but that will be very soon.
Send me an email and I will.
We'll do that.
Right.
Very nice talking with you.
Nice talking with you as well.
Thanks so much.
Alright,
bye.
Bye.